foreign
no matter if you are recently graduated
have experience in IIT field or are
seeking a career change these courses in
data science will provide you with the
necessary Foundation to pursue a
successful career in data science
obtaining an education in data science
can open doors to various job
opportunities such as data analyst data
engineer data architect or data
scientist your specific path in data
science will depend on your skills and
interests however all these career paths
require a certain level of proficiency
in programming data visualization
statistics and machine learning data
engineers and data Architects primarily
work with coding databases and intricate
queries while data analysts and data
scientists focus on analyzing collecting
and interpreting large data sets to Aid
in making informed business decisions it
is a rapidly expanding and financially
rewarding career path with data
scientists reporting an average annual
salary of 130 000 in the United States
and in India it is 12 lakhs per annum in
this simply land video on top courses
for data science we will explore some of
the top courses in data science
including what and Purdue IIT kanpur
Caltech and spjmir these courses are at
the Forefront of data Science Education
and Research their programs are designed
to equip students with the skills and
knowledge needed to succeed in this
exciting and rapidly evolving field but
before moving ahead do subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the Bell icon to
get all the updates from Simply learn so
let's get started first one on the list
is Caltech the California Institute of
Technology known as Caltech is a private
research University in Pasadena
California the University's division of
engineering and applied sciences offer
data science courses this data science
course curriculum emphasizes Hands-On
learning and encourage students to work
on projects that have real world
applications that's why simply learn has
collaborated with Caltech to create a
data science course that leverages the
superiority of caltex academic eminence
this data science course course critical
data science topics like Python
programming are programming machine
learning deep learning and data
visualization tools through an
Interactive Learning model with live
sessions by global practitioners and
practical labs this course also provides
a program certificate with up to 14 CU
credits from Caltech ctme and a course
completion certificate from caltex ctme
you will also earn membership to the
Caltech ctme Circle and an online
convocation by the Caltech program
director and last but not least hands on
experience with tools like numpy pandas
R Python and sci-fi with 25 plus
industrial relevant projects from the
likes of Walmart Amazon Uber
Mercedes-Benz and many more interested
in this course then do check out the
link to this course in the description
the second one on the list is Purdue
University Purdue is a public research
University located in West Lafayette
Indiana the University's Department of
computer science offers a data science
program covering data mining machine
learning and statistical modeling well
with simply learns post-graduate program
in data science in partnership with
Purdue University and in collaboration
with IPM you can have the opportunity to
take the advantage of master classes by
Purdue faculty and IBM experts exclusive
hackathons and ask me anything sessions
by IBM this program in data science is
perfect for working professionals and it
focuses on essential job skills like R
and Python Programming machine learning
NLP and data visualization with Tableau
to prepare for the job market you will
learn all this through live sessions
with experts Hands-On Labs IBM
hackathons and corporate projects this
course will also provide you with the
data sensor to get from Purdue the eight
most Innovative University in the US
along with IBM certificates from IBM
courses with this you will also get a
chance to build your resume and prepare
your interviews with valuable insights
from industry experts and 25 plus
industry relevant projects from Amazon
Walmart Uber and Mercedes-Benz you can
find the link to this course in the
description box and the third one water
wardon is a global technology company
that has been a leader in the data
science field for decades in addition to
offering a range of data science
Solutions and tools Horton also provides
training and education in data science
this AI program in collaboration with
vote on impacts in-depth knowledge of
Big Data Ai and machine learning and how
to apply them across the three key
business functions marketing finance and
people management this program also
covers the risks and ethics of using Ai
and how you can design governance
Frameworks for Effective AI
implementation apart from this you will
gain a certificate from work and online
the Wharton schools digital learning
platform and you will learn how AI can
be applied across business functions
such as marketing Finance HR and you
will also be having live master classes
from Top Morton faculty and get insights
on how AI is utilized across companies
like McDonald's visa and City Group this
program is designed to equip students
with the skills and knowledge needed to
succeed in this fast growing field and
become a data scientist by diving deep
into the nuances of data interpretation
mastering Technologies like machine
learning and mastering powerful
programming skills to take your career
in data science to the next level also
the link for this course is mentioned in
the description box following that we
have IIT kanpur the Indian Institute of
Technology kanpur is one of the top
engineering schools in India known for
its strong focus on research and
Innovation the institute's department of
computer science and engineering is one
of the most popular universities often
data science courses taking advantage of
such resourceful alumni simply and
provides a professional certificate
course in data science in collaboration
with IIT kanpur mastering essential data
science skills through applied learning
with live classes by industry experts
asynchronous videos Hands-On labs and
master classes from distinguished IIT
campus faculty along with that you will
get hands-on experience on 25 plus
industry relevant projects from the
likes of Walmart Amazon Uber
Mercedes-Benz and many more along with
career mentorship and profile building
sessions with valuable insights from
industry experts this course is designed
with a carefully curated curriculum that
includes critical topics like python
machine learning NLP and data
visualization delivered using Hands-On
labs and Industry relevant projects to
help you advance your career trajectory
this data science course in India aims
to demystify data science the link is
mentioned in the description box and the
last one is sp jmir spjn Institute of
Management and research is a leading
business schools located in Mumbai India
the institutes business intelligence and
analytics program is designed to provide
students with a strong foundation in
data science analytics and business
intelligence therefore simply learn has
collaborated with SPG Mir to design the
data science for business decisions
program that will help you learn this
in-demand skill set and turn yourself
into data-driven decision maker to
optimize your organization's performance
this program enables you to master the
concepts of machine learning statistics
data visualization Etc and create a
strategy to implement a data science
project in your organization this
program will help you drive digital
transformation in your organization by
understanding data privacy data
architecture and governance you will
also earn a program completion
certification from svjmaya a leading
School of Management in India and master
the concepts of data science through
live sessions delivered by SP gmir
faculty you will also back an
opportunity to Avail of spgi Myer
executive Alumni network membership post
program completion and so an experience
on multiple projects and a Capstone
pertaining to various industry domains
the link is mentioned Below in the
description with this we have come to
the end of this video I hope you find
this video informative and interesting
if you like this video give us a thumbs
up and share it with your friends also
if you have any questions about this
video please feel free to ask in the
comment section our team will get back
to you as soon as possible and all the
university courses covered in this video
The Links will be provided in the
description box below do check them out
thank you stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
foreign